Today in this video,
we are going to talk about euh constitutional rights and I will tell you the difference
between a unitary state and a federal state.
In order to understand the difference,
it is necessary to understand that each state has sovereignty
and that each state is sovereign.
There are 2 types of sovereignty,
internal sovereignty and external sovereignty.
The internal sovereignty of a state means that
it is sovereign within its borders.
Within its borders,
no entity,
no person has any power superior to it and cannot impose rules on it.
External sovereignty means that the state must not obey any other state and that
it is independent of its neighbors.
So we will see in the first part what a unitary state is.
A unitary state is a state that does not have on its territory and on the population
that lives there a single legal and political organization,
which is endowed with the fullness of sovereignty.
This means that in a unitary state,
power is centralized around the state and only the state has sovereignty,
that is to say that the sovereignty is not divided within the territory,
only the state has the fullness of the sovereignty.
Nevertheless,
it is possible for a unitary state to be decentralized.
This is the case in France as defined by Article 1 of the 1958 constitution,
which states that France is an indivisible Republic and that
its organization is decentralized.
Decentralization involves the transfer of administrative powers from the central
state to local entities which are called territorial collectivities in France.
Territorial collectivities have a certain autonomy but also their own budget to
implement the various powers that are theirs.
Nevertheless,
the powers that are attributed to them are attributed by the central state and they
remain under the control of the state,
which means that they are not independent.
In addition,
local governments do not have sovereignty.
In a unitary state,
as I said,
only the state has sovereignty.
Therefore,
local governments do not have this sovereignty,
they only have administrative powers.
For example,
they do not have regulatory powers.
The royal prerogatives are the most important powers of the state,
which concern matters of security,
diplomacy,
economy,
and also justice.
And within the framework of a unitary state,
only the state possesses equal powers and not the territorial collectivities.
In this regard,
Article 3 of the 1958 constitution provides that national sovereignty
belongs to the people and that no section of the people,
no individual can attribute the exercise of it.
Secondly,
a federal state is a sovereign state in which federal units possess
some of the sovereignty and also have a large degree of autonomy
and their own political organization.
What one must understand and always keep in mind is that in a federal
state there are always two different levels.
The first level is the federal state and this federal state
has superiority over the second level,
that is to say,
over the federated states.
The federal state has the fullness of sovereignty and in its constitution
it grants it to federal states,
1 sharing of sovereignty,
1 special autonomy,
provisions that are unique to them,
1 organization that is unique to them and 1 their own constitution.
If you want,
to make it simpler,
we can say that there is a kind of compromise between the federal
state and the federated states.
The federated state commits to respecting the constitution
of the federal state and in exchange,
the federal state recognizes a particular autonomy and a constitution for the federated
states that it must also respect.
The second tier therefore corresponds to the federated states.
The federated states therefore have a share of sovereignty,
they have their own constitution in addition to that of the federal state.
They also have their own political organization with their own government,
they have a capital,
a flag and they also have their own law.
For example,
in the United States,
some states allow abortion and others prohibit it,
or some states allow the death penalty and others prohibit it.
Thus,
in a federal state,
the balance must always be respected between the federal
state and the federated states.
The federal state must respect the autonomy of the federated states
and must not encroach on its powers,
but the federated states must also respect the federal state and submit,
uh,
to the requirements that are superior to them.